[Applause]
he was the de schoolchildren took over
the streets of power what was supposed
to be a contained climate protest by
Parliament spilled over fueled by social
media and became a takeover Westminster
ground to a halt fossil fuel engines
defeated by 3,000 pupils who then turned
on Downing Street a security alert
triggered by teenagers furious the
government wasn't doing more to cut
greenhouse gases at the moment way too
young to vote so at the minute there are
only really aiming their policies our
older citizens who can vote but we're
the future and we're who's going to be
voting in two years so they need to
listen the young people want to be heard
like we haven't had our saying it's
going to affect us if you have one
really good March where everyone listens
it's worth it to be part of the National
Curriculum and urged the government to
declare a climate emergency this is all
about frustration there's plenty of
evidence that climate change is already
happening and last year scientists
warned that governments in
taking action fast enough this is the
result children joined protests in 60
towns and cities around the country in
Brighton and in Cardiff
some had bunked off others had the
support of their schools well I don't
think it's a waste of time at all I
think there's a lot of learning going on
right now as we speak
those pupils behind me are being
interviewed by world media so they're
communicating their science knowledge
they're talking to people they've never
met before with the government seemed
unsure of how to respond but in an
exclusive interview with Sky News the
science minister offered his support
yeah I mean anyone who you know has a
passion is able to articulate that
passion about sort of what they consider
to be the key issues for the future I
think it's duty of government to be able
to listen and to engage all this
inspired by a 15 year old from Sweden
whose lone protest has grown into a
europe-wide school strike movement and
gave her a billing a December's climate
conference even if there is no hope we
have to do something that is not having
hope is not an excuse for not doing
anything because of course we need hope
but the one thing we need more than hope
is action because once we start to act
hope is everywhere another school strike
is planned for next month with many more
likely to abandon their classrooms in
the name of climate action Thomas More
Sky News